i tweeted out sorry not beautiful and
then everyone got upset yes they did
they had a rather overweight young woman
with a very revealing swimsuit on the
cover and i thought no the cover
bothered me a lot because it was a cheap
manipulation of something that had been
working very well for sports illustrated
it was also an insistence that all of a
sudden this non-athletic body is as
beautiful as the standard swimsuit model
it's not it's not as athletic and it's
not as healthy and that's that and then
it's a lie that's a manipulation of that
young woman they're not on her side
they're exploiting her and she may be
participating in that exploitation but
they're still exploiting her so don't
pull any moral stunts on me because
you're irritated about my opinion when
it's bloody clear to anybody with eyes
that that was manipulative in 20
different ways not everyone's a genius
not everyone's picasso not everyone's
young and healthy not everyone is a
sports illustrated swimsuit model period
and [ __ ] you if you don't like it